So what about biology in aggression? It turns out that overall gender is the
best predictor of aggression. Men being more likely to commit crimes such as
murder, battery and assault. Culture may also account for some of this in that
aggressiveness may be a product of socialization. It appears that many
societies encourage males to be more aggressive than females. But our biology
clearly plays a role too. Do you remember when we discussed testosterone in our
less non-motivational emotion? Well, testosterone is a male sex hormone.
However, you'll recall that women also have testosterone and that's important
for our sexual response. We see that testosterone is related to aggression. In
that those with higher levels of testosterone correlate positively with the
tendency towards aggression and violence. Now something else that's important
to aggression is serotonin. It turns out that low levels of serotonin actually
make aggression more likely in humans as well as in other animals. So we see
that our biology plays a role in aggression and our social influences can play
a role in aggression. Now, are boys aggressive in the same way as girls? And
how does the social world influence our aggressive behaviors. We see that boys
may model other boys or men and imitate aggressive behaviors such as, punching,
kicking and so forth. And then as for girls, we do see that they can be
physically aggressive. Often times, girls engage in what we call indirect
aggression. That's not necessarily hitting or punching but engaging in
behaviors that may exclude an individual. For example, girls may be more likely
to talk badly about a person, spread rumors about a person or make fun of a
person. Or generally just engage in ways to psychologically hurt an individual.
We can argue that the pain of being punched in the face or having rumors spread
about you can be very similar. Because as we've said a few times, the
experience of physical and psychological pain both activate the same areas of
the brain. Now, let's go back to Susan